hello everyone this is round four of the
tournament of the rapid tournaments in
st. Louis and Levin our engine is
playing Garrity's part of and the spiral
had three draws yesterday and well it's
a very exciting game as both of them are
pretty pretty dynamic players and before
I show you the game I just want to say
that yesterday I said that Nakamura made
an illegal move against Kasparov and
this wasn't true because the rule that
applies to this change in in 2014 and a
couple of chess arbiters contacted me
and they said that this is no longer so
so I do apologize for misleading you and
well still Nakamura for for saying that
he made an illegal move I was not aware
that this rule changed okay so let's see
the game Levin origin is white and Garry
Kasparov is black we have a d4 Knight to
f6 and nice to f4 and already when our
nm play Knight to afford the London
system Gary just shook his head and well
he definitely wasn't ready for this he
was preparing probably abroomfield
we have c5 by Gary and here are young
immediately captures with D captures on
c5 and cut power plays and Knight to c6
not going for East 6 to recapture the
point immediately
Knight to c3 we have E 5 and Bishop to
g5 Bishop captures on c5 and our own
place III not allowing any any Bishop to
Bishop captures f2 ideas I would have
bishop back to be 4 because Aragon
already lost the tempo playing Bishop f4
to g5 so now Bishop to b4 is a good move
or threatening to cut for the night and
a mess up White's pawn structure we have
Knight GTE 2 now protecting that knight
on c3
d5 by Kasparov we have 83 Bishop
captures on c3 and the Knight captures
on c3 and Kasparov place is Bishop to e6
not adding protection to that d5 square
we have a bishop to be 5 by RM and well
in this position because power plays a
d4 but they were analyzing this very
long variation which they didn't think
of Gary would see because it's a pretty
long line and it probably was too hard
to find and rapid it was the move 86 and
after 86 and
the bishop went the back pay for not
allowing the black not you know Aragon
wouldn't probably want to lose the
bishop there then something like d4e
capture some d4e capture sandy for
Bishop captures on f6 attacking the
Queen Queen captures on f6 now Knight to
e4 attacking the Queen Queen to e5
attacking the knight and after Queen to
e2 this
Queens the a5 move forking I mean
attacking the king and the bishop well
it was a pretty hard line to see and now
white loses a piece but after Bishop to
b5 as far plays d4 immediately so we
have Bishop captures on f6 Queen
captures on f6 and now Knight to e4 and
here cuz power plays a very sharp line
he plays Queen to g6 now attacking both
the knight on e4 and this pawn on g2 but
he he is allowing this nice to jump to
b6 and check the black skin so let's see
what would happen if our a nun did this
if nice of e6 check dunking c7 attacking
the knight so Knight capture some mb7
Queen captures energy to attacking the
rook to rope to f1 and now simply rook a
to be eight and well white has to do
something he's not this attacked and if
the knight moves the bishop fault
so simply Bishop captures on c6 Queen
captures on c6 and the United States a
five protecting Queen to c7 now
attacking the knight Knight to b3 and D
captures on e3 so pretty much a forced
line and it's pretty long line so after
because power play between to g6
rnm didn't really even probably want to
calculate this as it was a pretty long
line so he simply played a knight to g3
but it's questionable if the knight and
g3 has some bright future
we have castle by Kasparov and now
Queens the d3 our onion offers the trade
of Queen and here f5 is possible to go
for the attack but Kaspar decided to
trade Queens and he has a different
approach
he played Queen captures on d3 Bishop
captures on d3 and now at five and now
this is preventing this night for from
coming to e4 and well she's not very
happy on g3 we have a princess castle by
our
another spark plays D captures any 3f
captures on e3 and now this III porn
will be a permanent weakness because
fireplace a 6 we have night - E - E 4
and this this seems like Kasparov is
winning the bishop here because the
bishop has no squares to go to but he
does have this Knight to f4 moon our
technical sparse bishop on e6 we have he
captures from d3 Knight captures on e6
and now pawn captures on c2 now
threatening to capture the Rockwood
check so King captures on c2 and now
rook the f7 we have rook H 2 e 1 and now
rook to e8 attacking tonight so night
back to f4 rook F to e7 and now Knight
to d5 attacking the rook and okay rook
to e5 and now our any place roof - d3 to
add protection to this e3 pawn and
electic like I said the c3 pawn will be
a weakness for the rest of the game
so because part of this takes some time
here and he was at a 3 minute mark here
but he did spend about 30 seconds for
his next move and plays King to f7 so
it's a lot of time for for a king f7
move g3 and the spiral goes g5 repeated
e1 and now rub the d8 we have B fourth
rookie 38 and I'll rock the c3 Chris
power plays rook to e6 rook the c5 and
cut our goals are up to e5 and our onion
goes up to d3
now again protecting that III point we
have worked the d7 tonight to c3 and now
our engine offers the exchange of rooks
and the gari of course except rock after
sandy 3 King captures and III and our
local address on c5 b captures on c5 and
King to e6 would have e4 Knight to e5
checks in to e2 and now Knight to d7 and
now well Gary Kasparov is the winning
upon here we have P captures on f5 King
captures on f5 and there is no way to
defend this c5 pawn white could play
nice to a4 but then your nice is stuck
stuck on a for forever RNN could have
considered something like c6 perhaps
to give up the pawn but at least break
up for focus power spawns but he played
King to d3 because power plays and night
chapters on c5 with check King study for
now nights to be seven nights to e4 and
here because power in this position
because Faro was around ten seconds and
he played King to g4 and well in this
position he should have placed something
like h6 to protect this g5 pawn and then
he could seem to continue the game and
well probably probably because I won
this but he played a hint to g4 King to
g4 and gave Aragon this defensive
resource of h3 which check and he was
well you can see it was we're very angry
even though he was smiling and you know
he was shaking shaking his head well now
because part of could continue to play
this for example with King to h5 but he
was already down to three seconds when
he finally saw that - well his time will
run out and then he played King
characters on h3 just to go for a draw
we have night captors on g5 would check
King captures on g3 and our Anand didn't
even pick up this h7 upon but they
agreed to a draw so yeah definitely
definitely a great game the back
apartment this is his fourth game in a
row that that he gets out of the opening
with an advantage and it was a it was a
nice advantage so definitely he has to
improve improved something in the middle
game and that something is well as the
commentators say it's his time
management but I don't know it's
precisely his time management that
allows him to come with an advantage
from the opening stage so we'll see
we'll see what what Kasparov does in the
next two rounds that's it I do hope you
enjoyed this thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon oh yeah and as
usual you can check to my videos here
and meadow says hi